repeat after me i joseph robinette biden
jr
do solemnly swear hi joseph robinette
biden jr do solemnly swear
when joe biden was sworn in as our
nation's 46th president
he joined an exclusive but lesser-known
club of those who'd come before
joe biden is joseph robinette biden
jr one of 10 other commanders in chief
through history
named after their fathers others in the
group include
james madison junior theodore roosevelt
jr
and calvin coolidge jr
though there's a good reason few of us
are aware of the distinction
you know i'm not surprised that
presidents or any politician would
choose not to call themselves junior
because what is the word junior
but a diminutive it's it's saying you're
less or something or at least the very
most you're a copy of something
so we see presidents who found
themselves using junior
throughout most of their life but when
they wanted to get a public career on
their own
frankly they wanted their own name not
to be borrowing someone else's
the first president to carry the junior
suffix was the second to hold the job
john adams jr and there are plenty of
club members in the modern era
including one president who was a junior
twice
our 38th president was born leslie lynch
king
jr but his parents divorced and he would
later change his name to honor his
stepfather
becoming gerald rudolph ford jr
his successor is really james earl
carter jr
but turned that into jimmy carter
throughout his political career
and as for two former presidents who
joined mr biden
at the capitol wednesday former
president barack hussein obama also
bears his father's name but his parents
chose to add the roman numeral to
instead of the suffix jr happy birthday
sky king and ironically george w
bush son of george h.w bush was long
known to family members as
junior even though those varying middle
initials
technically keep him out of the
presidential junior club
there's really no reason for george bush
43
to refer to himself as junior though of
course in natural parlance people looked
at the names and said they sounded alike
so oftentimes throughout his early part
of his life
he was referred to as junior completely
understand why they knocked the junior
although all i can think of the whole
time
is raiders of the lost ark and junior
junior
i think junior sounds cool it's younger
vibrant
why didn't you you could have had a job
i could have i could have i didn't
sorry jack